hey everyone had a thought in these
strange times we've been asked to
practice social distancing one of the
problems with that is is that we're
social animals and when you take people
away from social animals it makes us
feel lonely makes us feel disconnected
and so I think we have to put an extra
effort to find ways to remain close to
people so just like when we're walking
down a hallway in the office and we
stick our head into somebody's office
and say hey how was your weekend let us
pick up the phone
let us have a FaceTime call or a zoom
call as often as possible
let us not rely on text remember we all
know that texting is already
disconnected and now that we have even
fewer opportunities to connect with each
other and we're isolated in our own
homes many of us alone when you want to
check in with someone please call please
get a videoconference because I know
that I would like it and I know that
other people would too stay safe
look after yourself and look after
others
[Music]